yesterday the president was also in the
state of nevada
no republican has won that state since
2004
but it's a battleground this year and
wii xi jiang is in las vegas for us
as a result of that wizard good morning
to you what's the president's campaign
strategy there to flip it into his camp
good morning
good morning tony and good morning to
everybody you know it is
all about face time with voters the
trump campaign is hoping what happened
here in nevada four years ago does not
happen
again president trump lost and his final
push out here is part of an intense
effort that's expected to include
up to five stops a day ahead of november
third
it's great to be back in nevada at a
packed rally sunday night president
trump courted voters
and slammed joe biden if he comes in
carson city will become a ghost now and
the christmas season will be canceled
earlier in the day the president
attended a church service in las vegas
[Music]
he received a blessing and issued a
warning to the congregation
you better get out because we have a
group on the other side that doesn't
agree with us
nevada is one of five states with a
covet 19
positivity rate higher than 20 percent
last week the president also held
rallies in iowa and wisconsin where he
was asked if he was sending the wrong
message
by holding large events during the
pandemic
well i don't think so because i'm not a
big shutdown believer
even after getting sick himself mr trump
continues to say the end of the pandemic
is near we're rounding the corner we've
got the vaccines all that but even
without it
we're rounding the corner but cases of
coronavirus are
rising in around 40 states a point
former vice president biden
seized on at a drive-in rally in north
carolina
this guy's gone around the bend if he
thinks we turn the corner
[Music]
turn the corner things are getting worse
since april the biting campaign has
outraged the trump team by more than
280 million dollars it's spending more
too
especially in crucial battleground
states
shelling out over 24 million dollars
more in florida
nearly 30 million more in pennsylvania
and more than
18 million in wisconsin as my coach used
to say in college it's go
time a senior trump campaign official
tells cbs news they
are announcing a significant advertising
buy
today later president trump will hold a
rally in arizona where the biden
campaign is also outspending him
by about 12 million dollars biden is
beating the president in statewide polls
there even though a democrat has not
won arizona since bill clinton in 1996.
tony all right rija thank you very much
and gayle and anthony as i sent it back
to you
we just mentioned the battle for the
airways there is also a ground game
battle a battle for turnout we're gonna
have more on that
later in the show but for now back to
you guys in new york all right we'll see
you later in the broadcast tony thanks